this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much before I start I'd
like to thank New York AG in markets
through the Empire State Development
Corporation and funded most of this work
I'd also like to thank the technician
team and the smart lab at Cornell a core
tech in Geneva and also the Rose and
vines lab for their help especially with
the HPLC so let's talk about cannabis
the best scientific research today
suggests that there's a single species
of cannabis cannabis sativa I its
distinguished legally into hemp and
marijuana hemp is less than 0.3 percent
THC THC being the psychoactive chemical
that you find in marijuana and marijuana
being above 0.3 percent THC and this is
simply the legal definition and it's
very important as I'll discuss later
it's a little bit about the biology of
cannabis it's diploid it's dioecious
meaning it has male and female plants
the male plants have an x and a y
chromosome the female plants have two x
chromosomes
there are also some plants that are
monoecious having male and female
flowers on the same plants and these
have two x chromosomes like the female
so cannabis can be grown for a wide
variety of things it's mainly grown for
a grain which can be pressed into a nice
oil and a nice protein rich fragment I
the fiber and also the inflorescences so
in the inflorescences particularly the
unpalatable inflorescences you can get a
high density of trichomes and these
trichomes produce very interesting
chemicals notably the cannabinoids like
THC and CBD
as well as terpenes which gave cannabis
its distinct smell so the major hemp
market with less than 0.3 percent THC is
currently CBD so there are a few
different factors which could
potentially affect CBD production female
versus male as I mentioned you want a
plot entirely consisting of unpalatable
inflorescences so you have to get rid of
the males the genetic control or recei B
D or THC is very interesting and I'll
discuss that later and you can also
imagine that there would be
environmental effects affecting these
traits so first off I'm going to be
talking about female versus male plants
there are a few different ways
to get a field full of females you can
grow from clones you can do a little bit
of hormonal trickery and create a seed
lot that consists only of xx females
unfortunately those seeds are quite
expensive it's not uncommon to see those
for sale at over $2 seed or you can
plant a regular delicious male and
female seed LOD and somehow get rid of
the males so perhaps the most
straightforward way to do that is to
just do it you know typically when you
see a male plant take it out that's not
so bad but if you're growing many many
acres that get very tiring because it's
about a 50/50 ratio and by the time you
see a male plant you're probably gonna
get some paw information and that can
reduce yields significantly so one of
the things that I did here that I'll be
talking about is development of a marker
that can distinguish the males from the
females so there are previously
published markers they're mostly based
on sequences specific to the y
chromosome six published sequences are
called male associated DNA of cannabis
one through six
unfortunately in their publications they
weren't tested on diverse germ plasm so
it's kind of hard to rule out that it
was just due to chance and they're also
lower throughput being gel or
electrophoresis based what I wanted to
do was create an assay that I could go
and screen thousands of plants at my
leisure and to do that I developed a
pace assay which is fluorescently based
so with this fluorescently based assay I
can just look to see is there
fluorescence of a certain color in my
assay and if so it's a male discard the
plant so I did this using the mad c6 by
aligning it to published xx genomes that
have been assembled unfortunately
there's still no published Y assembled
chromosome so we don't have all of the
data there which would make this a lot
easier so testing it on an initial panel
I found that there was separation
between the males and the females I then
tested it over several different
cultivars these are all unrelated
different numbers of males and females
and in every case I found that this
marker that I developed was a hundred
percent accurate
so I then came the the real acid test of
this marker for our 2019 CBD variety
trials we had 13 different diocese
cultivars that we wanted to only plant
the females out so we screened several
thousand plants we found a 50:50
segregation based on the separation as
you can see here in Part B so that was
very promising is that's what we were
expecting there's no call to bird where
it wasn't the case except for one uh we
planted out just the female plants and
thankfully we found that approximately
98% of the female plants that we thought
were female tended to be female an
additional 1% we're monoecious which is
what we were expecting
because as I mentioned before mono
lucious plants are xx and there's some
other factor which caused the domani
lucious and then the remaining 1% of the
ones that I tested it seems like it was
at least mostly original missed calls
and I tested the same font again it
showed up as a male so it looks like
there is a diagnostic sex linked marker
here so that's how we've been doing to
distinguish the males from the females
so the next thing that I'm going to talk
about is CBD versus THC before I go on I
just wanted to point out all of this
magic happens in this trichome that you
can see here particularly it happens in
that head so it's really interesting
about the CBD versus THC genetically is
that it's pretty much a single locus
it's called the B locus when it produces
mainly THC it's called the BT locus when
it produces mainly CBD it's the B V
locus uh so very recently there have
been several published genomes that have
found that it's not a single gene it's
two genes closely linked in repulsion
but it can be modeled monogenic li and
can be modeled monotonically very well
so just to go through briefly how it
works in that trichome head you start
off with this CB GA which is the
precursor if you have to be the alleles
which is the CBD a you get conversion
into CBD a if you have to be teal
that's the th CA you get th CA when you
have a heterozygous case you get one
allele of each and you get roughly equal
amounts of CBD a and th CA what's very
interesting is that the CBD and THC
which are the actual active compounds
that people are throwing this plant for
its not actually produced in the plant
itself it's only after you get
decarboxylation and that can be done
through heat or light or simply through
age so they go back to that 0.3% I
that's not actually the amount of THC in
the plant that's the amount of THC if
all of the THC a were decarboxylated and
converted to THC so given that it's a
single locus people have developed
diagnostic markers before especially a
University of Minnesota has done some
excellent work in this area but again
they're markers like the sextant ones
were gel or electrophoresis based and
therefore a fairly low throughput so
using their markers I developed another
pace assay that was high throughput and
tested it on some samples that we were
growing in 2018 for the CBD variety
trial now very surprisingly I found that
nearly a third of the plants by this
marker were heterozygous meaning that
they produced roughly equal amounts of
CBD and THC and again this is a single
locus so it seems like it would be a
pretty easy thing to breed for so we
were quite surprised to see that across
nearly every cult ever we tested there
is active THC a synthase genes producing
THC in these CBD varieties so this was
really surprising and this is just the
molecular data here and as you can see
it varies by a cultivar percent of the
bt allele so does this match what we saw
with the HPLC turns out that it does
turns out that some of the CBD varieties
that we're growing had individuals that
produce no CBD but high levels of THC
about a third of the plants or nearly a
third of the plants produced about equal
amounts of CBD and THC and then the rest
were mostly CBD which is what you're
expecting them all to be so we have a
to put marker now simple genetic control
should be easy to keep all of our plants
under 0.3% right unfortunately that's
not the case you can see this red line
here that's the 0.3% total potential so
that's what happens if you take all of
the THC a converted THC and as you can
see this blue group here which is the
mostly CBD group that's bbbb the line
formed by the blue dots there crosses at
around 6% now there was a study out of
Germany published in 2018
they found that isolated CBD a synthase
produces CBD and THC at a ratio of about
20 to 1
so if that in vitro were exactly the
same in vivo which is a big jump you
would expect to see that 0.3 times 26%
so there you see it cost around 6% so it
looks like the in vitro work matches the
in vivo work fairly well just to get a
close-up here so this is not the 2018
data but rather the beedi beedi group of
the 2019 data that we're still working
to process and you can see 0.3 crosses
this line between 6 and 7 percent so
this means that if you're growing hemp
for CBD and it gets above 7 percent
chances are it's going to be hot 48 you
see and that's a serious problem because
most farmers their lower bound is around
10% so this is going to be a serious
problem coming up so I guess I should
take a step back in the 2018 the farm
bill what changed was instead of just
looking at the THC they're looking at
total potential THC so last year it's
okay a lot of people passed unless they
were growing you know anything in the
the red or the green but in future years
if we're going to stay with 0.3 total
potential that's going to be a big
problem the last thing that we were
considering was maybe there's an
environmental effect can we fix that
ratio I didn't mention this before but
in the 2018 trials we had it replicated
in Ithaca and in Geneva so in in MA
for there that's including the trial as
a factor in the CBD to THC ratio and we
saw no statistically significant effect
so it looks like it's almost entirely
genetic what is kind of interesting is
that if you look at models 2 or 6 that
include the marker that doesn't actually
appear to affect the total potential
cannabinoids but if you look at any of
the models including the cultivar a does
so this CBD to THC ratio this marker
doesn't appear to affect total potential
cannabinoids what explains CBD to THC
almost entirely still in conclusion we
develop high-throughput sexy can have an
annoyed type markers develop them and
validated them we found that modern CBD
hemp cultivar populations are
segregating for collab annoyed type we
found very importantly that even in the
best case Beedie Beedie homozygous hemp
type or CBD type produces 0.3 percent
THC at around 7 percent CBD and neither
cultivar per se nor trial really
affected CBD to THC ratio and with that
I'd be happy to take any questions
[Applause]
yeah so the question is it so are the
first of all are the cultivars open
pollinated and it's delicious crop so I
guess it really depends on the skill of
the breeder if they kept the marijuana
plants the BT plants away from the BD
plants and scaled it up well that
shouldn't be an issue I think that the
problem is the breeding wasn't great so
I think their pollen control wasn't
effective which is why you're getting
introgression of these BT alleles we're
actively working towards that or sod is
there a better way to distinguish males
from females
I wish we are working towards that at
the moment nobody has convincingly
transformed cannabis so at some point it
would be great if we could make male
plants red but we're not there yet
has there been any research into curing
methods so maybe have these high CBD
lines is there whether you can cure it a
little bit differently so you're not in
NCHS so can you cure the planet
differently so you don't get a high THC
so the ratio of THC a to THC mattered
last year but this year it doesn't
matter at all so the actual plant is the
thing that's producing the CBD or a or
the THC a and then once the plant is
harvested it's pretty much set
but there's conversion of THC a to THC
after that and there could be
potentially methods of drying that would
change that ratio but with a 20-18 farm
bill and the more recent 2019 USDA
interim final ruling it doesn't matter
the THC its THC a-plus THC would people
be okay with the GM hemp plant no I say
no hemp has a bit of a reputation as a
hippie plant so I think people would be
against it on principle that's what the
general tone of cannabis meeting of this
I mean there's a lot of cool things you
could do if you could do it genetically
modified cannabis plant but market wise
I don't think we're there as a society
yet I mean put in an AI you don't grow
the nails yeah but it doesn't get into
the hybrid so that's how the Japanese
market opens up real quick doesn't
because it doesn't go into the problem
accepting maize
hybrids are produced by TM process
because the TM doesn't use a dive as one
last minor note if I'm talking about
society of cannabis which is a lot of
fun by the way so there's a lot of
misinformation out there and even
reputable CBD provider or the seed
providers or clone providers they'll say
that even feminized seeds are
genetically modified when they're
clearly not it's strictly a hormonal
treatment so there's no genes changed
but you look at their website and they
say we don't sell them and I see because
it's genetically modified it's a lot of
fun let's take it one more time this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu